news now well tomorrow is st patrick's
day and we're heading to new york
to get a sneak peek at all the safe fun
they're planned yeah of course we're
talking about the new york new york
hotel
on the strip rocky theist joins us there
live hey rocky
hey you guys yes so we are already
having a lot of fun here
for st patrick's day which is tomorrow
of course where we're getting the party
started early
because the new york new york has so
much planned so
let's start with the drinks because you
can't do saint patty's day without
drinks and i'm going to take a wild
guess as to what
goes into a saint patrick's day drink
i'm looking back here
sour apple sauce not really
no no i mean it's the color though it's
a good color yes for say patties
you don't want to get pinched okay
you're right but no not really we don't
put apple stuff in our in our especially
okay so then let's talk about what you
do offer okay
well one of our famous shots here is our
green teaser shot
um it's a green tea shot but we call it
the green teaser
quote-unquote i love it um so it has
jameson peach schnapps sweet and sour
and the most important ingredient is
love oh that's so sweet
yes
oh that is that is delicious yeah i like
that i could finish that but i won't
absolutely
i won't finish it she can but she won't
all right so now let's talk about
the famous one the number one that you
guys actually have on the menu all the
time yeah
what's that called um well we have an
irish mule um our mule kick is one of
our most popular drinks
but since in saint patty's we definitely
want to highlight jameson
and we're using that for our irish meal
so our jameson
oh whoa wait a minute here
is what we use um now this is in our
well this is a premium spirit in our
well so if you go to tom's urban
our well has premium spirits in there so
i love that you definitely want to make
sure you check out this cocktail
all right jameson's famous saint
patrick's day absolutely so while you
make that jay why do you think that and
you get all fancy over here i'm going to
talk to jason over here
who runs things okay so jason let's talk
about how people can enjoy
st patty's day here in new york new york
in general yeah so
as you can see new york new york is the
ultimate destination for
for a fun and a safe st patrick's day
but tomorrow
we are going to have multiple food and
beverage specials here at toms urban
as well as our nine fine irishman irish
pub
as well as on a bridge so out on our
brooklyn bridge
out front so you can enjoy beer gardens
you can also enjoy our pepsi wild cherry
experience on the center bridge
uh interactive games uh it's just a lot
of fun
okay well i'm looking forward to that
coming up later in the show we're
actually going to go check out
everything you just mentioned on the
brooklyn bridge
doesn't get much better than that all
right you ready you're gonna you're
gonna have to
help me garnish this oh oh wait a minute
i gotta wrap it up i gotta rest
yeah here we go there it is boom we're
ready to drink
that was awesome i'll send it back to
you guys
cheers cheers she gets all the good
assignments wow i'm jealous